you started this bit where you would
have and we talked about this before
yeah you have a weatherman who reads the
weather and you got Brad Pitt to do it
Brad what Brad Pitt asked to be on the
show and I said sure I think he was
going through a divorce or something I
know and you don't read the day
something was yet sometime yeah anyway
so so so he said he'd come on the show
and then he did it like five or six
times yeah we have a picture of him here
doing the weather on your show yeah yes
and then what happened was it got to the
stage we did six of them and I thought
he can't be enjoying this anymore he
must have more of a life than this and
so I asked Seth Rogen to do it right yep
and and now I feel I saw Seth Rogen's
doing it now yeah and then I bump into
Brad Pitt and Brad Pitt goes me so your
place the weatherman and I'm like I
think I've upset him we have a weight
thing I have a huge crush on braids he
is just so wonderful he's like even more
handsome when you meet him he does a
wonderful thing when you tell a story to
him he touches his forehead then shows
his teeth you got you got a stone anyway
so my dad took a picture of the boots
and he goes
learn that that's fantastic yeah so he
took pictures of the booth then what
happened and then I'm like I'm not very
handy in two years I don't get it anyway
so I pissed off Brad Pitt I think I
think we're friends we've got each
other's number but whenever I text him I
get a little bit nervous like I could
text you all right I've met you a lot no
if you didn't text me back so it's being
born with me die yeah look I can admit
it you know I'm not Brad Pitt you know
no shocker but you can text Conan
O'Brien and if you ever don't get back
to you it's isn't ruin your day all
right takes Brad Pitt one time we were
every other totally text about the
weatherman part and then I just text him
like like hey Happy Thanksgiving
yeah it's about four hours past I was a
Miss Walker Thanksgiving guys I
shouldn't have done it I put an emoji at
the end or what you gonna think there's
an emoji
I swear it out I'm eating Turkey and my
ex is there with a football boyfriend me
girlfriend the kids they're all
panicking it takes a village and they go
I'm sure you'll take back and then baby
baby hey Happy Thanksgiving man
[Applause]